Now today we're going to be talking
about musical impressionism.
Next time modernism, but today, musical
impressionism, impressionism, uh,
generally speaking is a period in the
history of music running from 1880 to
1920.
It's mostly a French phenomenon,
although it did expand as
we will see to England,
into Italy and to the United
States even to some degree.
We have the American impressionist
school of art, for example. Uh,
let's turn to the board here and
visit some familiar names and faces.
You know, of the painters,
Manet, Monet, Renoir, Alfred, cc,
Camille Pizarro, and the American.
Interestingly enough, American woman,
Mary Cosat,
anytime on art museum needs to raise cash.
What sort of exhibition do they put on a
blockbuster exhibition of impressionist
painting?
That's what brings everybody in.
It is the locust somehow of
what art is supposed to be.
Everybody loves these
impressionist exhibitions,
whether it's Boston, New York,
Chicago, wherever it might
be. So we have those artists.
We also have the poet's though,
interestingly enough,
they're not called so
much impression as poets.
They're called the symbolist poets.
And I'm sure in literature
classes and in French classes,
you have studied some of them. Uh,
Charlotte [inaudible] poll of Ireland,
Arturo Humble and, uh, Stefan malar May.
Turning now to the composers.
The most important of these
really is Claude Debussy.
He sort of started this
school of French composition,
the impressionist style.
Uh, we list others up there.
Maurice Ravel,
we've bumped into Balero of ravel.
Gabrielle for Ray wrote some
beautiful impressions. Music.
You may have heard of parts of the foray,
requiem from time to time or to Reno
RSPB and Italian suggesting that there's
also got to Italy and the American Charles
Griffis who died of the influenza in
New York City,
but wrote some impressionist
piano in orchestral music.
Uh, in terms of the works
of these individuals.
We've listed more over here
for Deb UC than anyone else.
Uh, Clair de Lune that we're going to be
talking about today. That's important.
A prelude to the afternoon of a fawn
will be a hearing, some of that.
And you have your listening exercise
40 on the prelude to the afternoon of a
fawn. Uh, other orchestral pieces,
a nocturne sort of night mood pieces,
law mayor,
a big orchestral
composition, a Emr, more uh,
uh,
orchestral works and then preludes for
piano and will be a foregrounding goes
preludes for piano.
I'm here today and a couple of
pieces we list on the board,
the own dean from guests Barden re uh,
that will be performed for us later in
the hour today and the Bolero that we
have mentioned before. So
those are the players. Uh,
let's take a look now at,
at what this music sounds like.
I'm going to start with playing some
of this piece that you all know.
I'm sure you've heard this
before, Claire de Lune, 1890.
We'll pick it up from
there and just a moment,
but obviously we've talked
a little about this before,
this general relaxation caused by the
falling down motive only to rise up at
this point,
but also of interest here is the absence
of any kind of clear cut and meter.
That's I think the big ticket item here.
You'd be hard pressed to tap your foot
to this, to conduct this in any way.
So that takes us through, Oh, the
first to 1215 bars of this piece.
Now a different kind of music.
Just pause on this for a moment.
I'll be emphasizing the phenomenon
of parallel motion today.
Parallelism today.
And here's a moment,
all the voices,
they probably have six different notes
in that cord,
but the next one,
all six are going in the same direction
rather than having going in the opposite
direction. We'll continue to
elaborate on that as we proceed.
Okay.
Now another idea comes in here.
Lovely,
really nice.
Could Be Chopin, right? That
kind of rich sale almost guitar,
like a company underneath it.
But it's something really neat happens
here,
this cord.
And then we have this
kind of a surprising or
shocking unexpected core.
So that's something else we get here
when this impression, that style,
unexpected cords, new
chords, uh, we might have
normally then we've good go
got a Beethoven type cell,
but getting
going to not courts a
fourth or fifth away,
but courts just a third away.
Yeah.
Well that's another
interesting moment we've had,
we've got this sound here to begin with.
Well, that's kind of, and
then the next chord is
we haven't had those cords before. We've
had major triads, we've had minor triads,
we've had diminished triads,
and now we got the kind of flip
side of the diminished triad,
the augmented triad.
This is the fourth of our triage
major,
a major third on the bottom and
minor third on top minor changes,
those around minor third on
the bottom of major on top,
major minor.
And we could have when he got the sharp
biting cord called the diminished,
if we have just two minor third, just
in most narrow of the, of the triad.
But supposing we had
two major thirds in this aggregate.
Yeah, that kind of sound well, it's a
little bit weird. So we get once again,
a new cord here with the impressionists,
the augmented triad,
and they liked to kind of pile them up
in this fashion.
Different sounding kind of
a strange sense. All right,
well that's a little bit of Clair de Lune
of Claude Debussy and that introduces
us to the impressionist style.
We're going to move on now
to first the first, uh,
orchestral piece of WC.
And that's the prelude to the
afternoon of a fawn that's, uh,
listed on the board there in 1884,
uh,
WC lamented that he had never
created a masterpiece. Well,
he sort of did with this piece. It's a
really a wonderful, wonderful composition.
Goes about 10 minutes and
you've got the full, uh,
composition there on
your CD. Number five, uh,
what can we say about it? Well, first of
all, prelude to the afternoon of a fawn.
It's point of inspiration was a poem
by Stephane Mahler. May Malheur,
may was a, uh, an aesthetic mentor
of WC. They were close friends.
Once a week they would meet and
talk about aesthetic issues, uh,
in Paris on the blue bar
Montparnasse area. Uh,
so he Mahler may co had written a
poem called the afternoon of a fawn.
Now, this fallen here is not faw
n the little baby deer type form,
but FAU in sort of Randy Sater,
a half man,
half beast who spends a his afternoon in
pursuit of sexual gratification in the
heat of the, of the Mid Day
Sun. So it's a bit more, uh, uh,
sexually supercharged. Then
the story of Bambi. Uh,
let's go on and think about, uh, the
type of music that we're about to here,
uh, here. Uh,
it's a different kind of music and maybe
the best thing to do is just jump into
it.
For us,
it's difficult to appreciate how
strange this must have sounded.
We're kind of used to this sound we've
got and maybe you've heard augmented
triads and there are a lot of
major seventh chords in Debussy.
Sounds a bit like a jazz chord.
Yeah.
Because jazz performers like that sound
that they heard it in an impressionist
and, and they, they, they, they,
uh, um, uh, drew it into their,
their music.
So there are strange cords here,
but there's also a strange
orchestration. And once again, it's,
we should remember how unusual this
must have sounded at the time it was
created.
So let's listen to a little bit of the
prelude to the afternoon before and
picking it up about,
it's a internal reform.
We're picking it up and return to a see
if you can tell me what the meter is
here.
Okay, let's just pause it there for a
moment. Anybody know what the meter is?
No,
I don't either.
I'd have to look at the score and I
never look at the score for this course.
It seems like cheating. I shouldn't
have any more advantage than you do,
so it's a little hard to know what it,
what it is there.
I'd really have to go get the music and
find out what it is there a you heard
kind of little harp Glissando
is in the background.
We'll be talking more about that.
The harp playing away.
There are page shows up periodically.
Dtt, Ttt, TTT. Did EMT team,
just little dabs of color underneath
by way of a supporting a compliment.
Sean, let's listen to a
little bit more. Uh, here.
Focus on the flute line
that's got the melody,
but it's a kind of different melody
than the melodies that we have been
listening to
passed it to the oboe.
Okay. Pausing it there. So that melody,
it was a kind of like, uh, uh,
your form in a way. It's
a, it's a very beautiful,
but it's kind of difficult to sing.
It's chromatic.
It doesn't have any
regular structure to it.
And this is typical of the
impressionist approach to melody.
Well, as I say, this was
somewhat shocking at the time.
This is Debbie [inaudible] response
to a poem and you have the poem there.
It's given to you on the sheet for today.
Everybody got the sheet?
We're not going to read it
because we don't have time for it.
It's a good example.
However,
it's a wonderful example of this symbolist
poetry where the meaning comes not
from any kind of logical,
uh, uh, semantic,
no syntactical presentation of ideas,
one word following the
next logical fashion,
but just sort of placing keywords at
interesting moments that stimulate our
thinking, have these words have
resonance in and of themselves.
Uh, and I think that in some ways gets
to the essence of this symbolist poetry.
So you can take a look at
that on your own there. Uh,
so Deb UC was not trying to
write program music here.
He was just trying to use this as a
point of point of inspiration. Um,
and here's what he said at the time
about his approach to this piece.
The piece is really a sequence of mood
paintings throughout which the desires
and dreams of the foreign move
in the heat of the afternoon.
So Miller may then went to the first
concert of this, of this piece,
and here's what he said,
intern about Debussy's music quote.
I never expected anything like it.
The music prolongs the emotion of
my poem and paints it scenery more
passionately than could
colors, paints. It paints it.
So music as painting.
Well,
with this idea of music as painting,
because these two artistic disciplines
cannot be separated really from one
another.
Let's turn to our first slide for
today and we'll see how this works.
Okay.
What's this?
Anybody know this?
Yeah.
Kind of a classic of impressionist
painting like Grand [inaudible],
the frog pond, uh, painted by Monet.
I don't know the date,
probably 1874 75,
I would guess.
Um,
and we get kind of this general impression
of it if we look however at the brush
work of it. And let's go to
that. It kind of close up.
We,
we see here we are,
that it's really made up of a series of
individual gestures. Here's a mark there,
mark there. And so, but when we, let's
go to the next slide, stand back.
We do get this sort of shimmering
impression and there'll be a lot of that.
The same kind of effect worked out
in music. Yes, you can have a cord,
but that cord could be
played as an Arpeggio and you
could pedal with it and you
could play it very rapidly and you
wouldn't notice the individual notes.
You would kind of get the effect of
the impression of this general wash of
sound.
So that in some ways is a similarity
here between these two artistic
disciplines. Uh, let's go on to the
next or maybe that makes that point.
Oh No, this is fine. We're going
to go onto a sailboat here now. Um,
and we need mentioned
where this comes from,
but this is a picture of
sailboats sort of Luffing, uh,
more or less listlessly at,
at anchor here at a harbor,
probably out near [inaudible] to you,
a few miles to the west of Paris.
Uh,
and with this as something of a visual,
the setup.
Let's turn to the next piece by Deb UC.
It's one that you have on your cds.
It's called a wall or sales from these
preludes for piano of 1910 and I'm going
to start just by playing and then we'll
talk about what it is that I'm playing.
Right?
Okay.
Stop there.
All of that music up to that point is
made up out of a new kind of scale scale
we haven't talked about before,
but now's the time.
It's called a whole tone scale.
Remember when we,
our off
we start,
may take a major scale in there are active
divided into seven different pitches,
five whole steps and half steps.
Uh,
but supposing we, we traded in those
two half steps for one whole step.
So instead of
go ahead
see to see you in that fashion, we would
be going, no, I got to do a whole step.
So that's a whole tone scale.
All wholetones within the
octave for total of six of them.
They're just converting to halftones into
one whole time. So all of this business
and so I'm just running up and
down a whole tone scale. All right.
Then at this point where we stopped.
Yeah.
Nice. There. Uh, you're, you're listening
to the whole tone scale up above,
but underneath we're getting
rocking and anchor.
What is this in music?
Let's repeat something over and
over again. Hey Jay. Ostinato.
Thank you very much.
So we have Austin autos coming back into
music here in the impressionist period.
Uh,
they were there in Baroque music.
They kind of went out of fashion in the
classical period and in the romantic
period, romantic is too
expansive for Austin autos,
but they come back in here
and impressionist period.
And they're really important
in the modernist period.
So it's a harbinger of things to come
in the modernist period. All right,
now let's go on just a little bit farther.
Well, you can hear the Austin auto
up above and that's a good idea.
Samples,
parallel motion,
all the cords going up and
going down at the same time.
Right.
Stop there. What's that? Well,
it's a class cause exactly.
Hold on.
I've a Glissando right?
Is that a lot in television stuff?
What's behind curtain number six?
Three,
tell us van or whatever.
Um,
so it simply playing a Arpeggio
and Arpeggio and very rapid,
very rapid family. Oh,
you could have fashion.
Hmm.
It'd be another sort of Glissando just
playing every white note or, yeah,
three black note. Okay. Up on
the keyboard. So I had this book.
All right.
Now let's talk about the scale we have
here because he's actually changed scales.
We did have whole tone,
but now we get
a pentatonic scale.
Just using five notes.
We've bumped into the pentatonic scale
before anybody remember when way back
early on Roger?
I didn't hear that a
little bit loud. Uh, yes.
To some extent. It was in that lecture
when we were talking about blues.
Blues tends to use more of a six node
scale. Um, but it was at that very point.
What kind of music was it? Emily?
Chinese music. Good for you.
Chinese music.
We had the moon reflected in the distant
pool and it was played by an r who,
well here we have another five
note scale. Uh, did they evolve?
Homesteads and minor thirds.
Simplest way to think of it as just the
black notes of the keyboard and that's
kind of what he's using.
Oh.
Now one other interesting thing
going on and that is the combination
of which is what he's doing here of
parallel motion and the pentatonic scale
because,
hmm.
Does that conjure up any, the Chris is
smiling down here. Why are you smiling,
Chris? What does that remind you of what?
All right, the Far East indeed, but
when I was a kid growing up, if I heard
I would be watching Indians coming over
the horizon and the west and the good
guys are, the bad guys are chasing
her. It was a sign of the Indians.
What this was,
what this became in terms of film.
Music was a kind of racial
stereotyping we had.
US and US went along in major and minor
scales and we had these other people
generally moved in parallel motion
and used a lot of pentatonic sounds.
So the people in Hollywood were,
we're painting here ethnically
with a very kind of blunt brush.
It was us in Hollywood in major and
minor and functional harmonies and it was
them who went around in pentatonic
scales. Um, and in parallel motion.
It's a very interesting
kind of moment there in the,
the history of American
musical culture in a way.
Uh, so in any event that's, that's
what we have in this particular piece.
WC is using this here and I'll come back
to this a little bit later on because
WC was very much influenced and we
can document where and why very much
influenced by the orient by the east.
He was hearing these eastern
sounds in Paris beginning in 1889.
All right,
well then this thing goes
because back to our whole
scale, a whole tone scale. Then
he instructs the pit,
the pianist there just to leave the
foot on that sustaining pedal there.
That right most pedal,
the sustaining pedal.
So we get again this wash of sale.
Okay. Now, one other point about pedals.
While I've got the uh, well I have,
I met the keyboard here at my heavens.
Look what time it is already. Um,
and that is the following. Uh, we've
talked about the right most pedal
gives us this kind of wash down.
What's it called once again?
Okay.
What's the right most pedal
called on the piano. Yeah,
we to hear it over here.
Who's got it?
Christian. Okay. Who said that? Please.
Okay, thank you. This is the sustaining
pedal, right? It gives us the wash of Sam.
What's the left most pedal do?
Okay.
Um,
Frederick,
that's right.
Moves the whole keyboard over.
So those hammers are only striking
two strings rather than striking three
strings. It makes it a little softer.
A The middle most pedal, however, uh,
is a very interesting one. Uh, it
doesn't get used nearly as much.
And I was thinking this
morning was looking at my
office on my Steinway upright
and there is no middle pedal.
Uh,
and that's because it doesn't get used
very much, but when it does get used,
it's used for, um, sort of special effect.
Let me show you a good example in
another prelude of Debussy. Um,
and this is a bit Oh,
hokey I suppose,
but it's called the luck,
had a drought or glue t the Gulf,
there's soaking cathedral. Um, and of
course, Monet painted of the Cathedral,
uh, over and over again, all sorts of
different views of this [inaudible] role,
uh, in different kinds of
lights, which gets Ebro was it
okay?
[inaudible]
okay.
No. Any art and the folk say
or show Jacob what, which,
which cathedral is it that won't
show the next slide, please?
Well, we can't, we won't tell them. It's
an impression of the Cathedral of wall,
which is about a hundred miles
or so up the up river, uh,
no downriver toward the mouth
of the sin. So you go, uh,
the sin toward Har Flair and you
come to war and he painted this.
And Debbie see also,
uh,
constructed a musical equivalent
of it that goes this way.
Notice all the parallel motion here.
All right,
so then the sun comes up on the Cathedral.
Let's see if we can get the sun to come
up here a little bit on our cathedral.
There we go. A little bit Sunnier. Uh,
and we get this kind of music and we'll
get to our, um, middle pedal here.
Well now Debbie, she was going to
show you what the bells sounded like,
all the cathedral,
but as is the case with most of
these French cathedral bells,
there is one bell. It's called the
board Dole, this huge, big low bell.
Uh,
and he's trying to give us the impression
of the Bordeaux here and he instructs
that we should use the sustain at
the, excuse me, the Sostenuto pedal.
This is a bit counterintuitive because
we have the sustaining pedal to the,
right now we've got this thing called
the Sostenuto pedal. It also sustains,
but it sustains in a different way.
It allows you to hit a note,
hold that note,
and then you can play other stuff.
And it was clear that other
stuff with your sustaining pedal,
while that note is still sounding down
there and he uses it here to get the
effect of this large bill,
she does,
her bells sounded
and then a fade out at that point.
Okay.
Um,
so that takes us to the end
of this particular of prelude.
Now have a lot of other things I'd
like to say about impressionist music.
Very interesting stuff. I think I'm
going to cut to the chase however,
with just showing you a few slides,
because we have a guest that we want to
talk with a and she is here and we want
to move on to that,
um,
in the textbook and you can read about
this and the impression has chapter in a
textbook.
Let's go on Jacob to the next slide.
And the point here is the,
uh,
association of Color. And, uh, Linda,
if you would cue the Tarkovsky,
which, uh, should be,
uh, track I guess 15 is it? What
is the checkoffs skews ready?
Cool.
Um,
so we're going to make a point here and
that is that musicians in this western
tradition of Bach,
Beethoven and Mozart and so on,
always tie line to color in a section.
One day,
I think it was Roger.
Where's my,
Roger asked me.
There he is back there.
How do we know it's a melody?
Well,
one reason we know in all this complex
of music, it's something is a melody,
is that in orchestrated pieces, when
it's melody time, the composure,
we'll bring in a new instrument.
It's like, it's like telling you,
holding up a sign again, hey, here's
the melody. Instruments are quiet.
Then they come into play the melody.
So let's listen to a famous passage of
Chekhov ski here out of Romeo and Juliet,
where he work up nicely in the strings.
When we get to melody.
Time incomes, the flute playing
the melody and a French Horn,
no enters to play in the company.
Mint with it,
melody time.
All right, so let's, let's stop with
that. Now that's one, that's one approach.
But Debbie, she starts doing
something a little bit different.
He's going to start working just with
color, just with color a little bit if,
if we can get to it of an
orchestral piece, but what,
but WC where he's using a new instrument.
It's the human voice. What's the,
what's the uh,
instrument singing here?
Okay, we'll stop. Time is
short, uh, not singing much of
anything. Just thinking, oh,
it's just what he wants.
There is the warm sound,
the stable warm sound of
the human voice and uh,
as Thomas Mann mindset and uh, he just
brings that in a little dab of color.
They're a little dab of color there.
What's interesting him is
not wine but just color.
He's going to pulling
color away from line.
And that begins to happen here
in the painting of the period,
the begin to intensify color
and a separate color from line.
Here we have Matisse 1909,
the dancers,
this is version one of this.
You may not know that he actually
painted this particular scene twice.
Version one notice.
Just the kind of flesh tone colors.
Notice the position of the knees.
Now we're going to go to version two,
two years later,
much more intense.
The position of the legs and the,
um,
a hamstring tear is much more angular
and we have a much more visceral response
to this because of the addition
of the red color to it.
And red becomes a very important color
with the painters of this period,
and they begin to take this color and
just play with the color itself outside of
line, which is what WC is doing. So
let's go onto the next slide here.
Here is Matisse's red studio,
for example,
where the color red begins to overrun
everything. Or in musical terms,
let's go to Duffy's red violin here where,
where the red varnish quality of the
violin is spilling out outside of the line
or normal confines of the instrument.
So that's an interesting point, I think,
to watch these two arts work in tandem
at this particular moment in history.
All right, I'm going to
stop here and introduce our
guests. Uh, Naomi. Woo. Naomi,
come on up. I've never met Naomi, right?
But it's nice to see you. Thank
you for joining us today. Um,
so you're a pianist here
at Yale. Um, and talk,
how are we doing out there? I'm told
that when we have guests that, uh,
sometimes we don't foreground the guests
enough. We don't, he can you see a c?
I'm okay. Okay. June. Great. So, um,
here's what you owe me and we're
going to turn the lights back on.
So tell us about yourself nice
and loud if you would please.
Are you a music major?
Um, I'm not sure yet. I'm a
freshman. You're a freshman.
Probably won't be a music major,
but I am looking to go to Grad
school and music probably.
Interesting. So why did you, why didn't
you go to Julliard then or you Smith?
I, I actually decided to come here because
I wanted to do a liberal arts degree.
Still pursuing,
I thought really seriously about going
to Juilliard and then realize that I
didn't want to be sort of at
a vocational school right now,
going to be so focused right now and I
find you should get a broader education.
That's a smart move. I did it the
wrong way. I went to, I went to, um,
and it was a red or wrenching experience
to go to the Eastman School of music
first and then go to Harvard after that.
That,
that because you really felt
like a dummy. Uh, at least I did.
And then rightfully so. So you're doing
it the correct way. I think generally,
whatever your trajectory is in
terms of your particular profession,
get your broad and liberal arts background
first and then focus more and more,
uh,
more intensely on your specialty and then
sub specialty in on it on it will go.
So here you are taking piano lessons.
With whom do you study?
Um, could we gang at the, he teaches,
uh, so, so he is a faculty member of
the School of music across the street.
And our most talented undergraduates go
over there to get their lessons and they
do their practicing. How many
hours a day do you get to practice?
I tried to practice two hours a day,
but I usually can't do it everyday.
It's probably five days a week.
Okay, well then, yeah, that's hard.
That was the thing was so weird about
these conservatories. These kit,
we go down and you go in these practice
rooms and six hours later they come out.
I mean,
they spend their entire time and there
was like learning to be a great plumber
or something like that. It's, it's
not a very broadening experience. Um,
okay.
So you're practicing two hours a day.
Does that annoy the people all around you?
Well, they're, they're great
practice rooms. I'm in the
basement of Sprague hall.
Okay. Uh, but how, I thought that was
just for, uh, the school of music students
for the, for the Undergrad students who
are, who are studying at the school of,
okay.
Give us Keith.
I see. So you're kind
of a special group. If,
if Daniel decides he wants to practice
over there, they're not Gullah.
Daniel have a key to the key to
this, the treasury. Uh, okay.
But we are a red course. Cross street.
What are we building over there?
I knew music department buildings are
gonna have a lot more practice, uh,
facilities in the basement
of that, principally for
undergraduates. All right. So,
uh, this is something that
always interests me. We have
a time to talk about it.
Um, how good is your, you know, these
kids that are good at this music business,
they're good for a reason.
Um,
it's because they have some talent and
oftentimes this is orally perceived
talent. So how good an ear do you have?
I'm not going to quiz you on this.
I like to quiz people on this,
but tell me about this.
No,
I mean,
I haven't really good ear and I don't
know how much of that is innate or whether
it's because I've been listening
to music since I was a kid.
My parents were always playing.
Were they musicians, not musicians at
all? What do they do? My mom's a doctor.
My Dad's an economist. Okay. So they're
in the quantitative reasoning in,
in some kind of some kind of way. And
this is not incidental folks. Yeah.
And I'm actually considering
majoring in math actually.
Oh yeah. I knew that it was coming.
So you may not have absolute pitch.
You probably don't have
absolute pitch, right? No.
But you probably have a very
good sense of relative pitch.
What would have happened if you
started out well, what was piano?
Your first instrument? It was, it was
supposing you had started out on at it.
And what, how old were you
when you started? Five. Okay.
So you were a late starter by,
uh, uh, sometimes you know, um,
Ken show who is in here.
What did he say?
He was three when he started
with the violet. How'd you
start it with the violin?
Do you think you would
have absolute pitch?
You know, definitely. I think
I would have, I, I, I do play
violin. I play on the why.
So
wait a minute. You play
violin also? Really? Yeah.
You're playing the Yso uh,
you know, that's really hard
to get in the YSL folks.
That's a very competitive,
oh, okay. So when,
how old were you when you took a flight?
Yeah,
hi. When I was 10, and I, my sense of
pitch didn't develop for the violence.
Okay. So what did you learn
from that? What do we,
what do we conclude from that experience?
If you wanted to develop?
Absolute pitch.
What would have been the sequence in
which you would have been exposed to these
instruments?
Violin first,
because it forces you to think
about pitch constantly, like the um,
uh, eastern languages are, so
many of them are tonal languages.
You have to think about this issue of
pitch early on and statistically you,
somebody did a study of, of uh, uh,
violinists of Asian nationality or
descent at the Eastman School of music and
shopping like 64% of
them had absolute pitch.
Uh,
and it's a combination I think,
of working with a string instrument and
working with a tonal language and in
many cases. So it's a very interesting,
interesting phenomenon. And it, sure. It,
sure.
It's very helpful when you go to play
these instruments because you don't have,
you know,
if you can stream the music,
you're not going to have memory lapses
and things like that. So now we have,
we have a piece and we're going
to have you, you play, uh,
this piece on Dean for beginning to end.
It's based on another poem we've
given you the poem for today,
but it's not really relevant.
Uh, or that relevant.
What's this poll about Naomi? Have you
ever looked at the Pomona? So what's,
what's it,
what's it do for us?
The poems about a water man and she's
trying to seduce this mortal man and um,
she sings and she asks him to sort of
come into life with her and be the king of
the, the, the lake with her.
Um, and he, in the end he says,
no, I can't. I love a mortal woman.
And she begins to cry a little bit and
then she just laughs it off and basically
says, well, I didn't want to do, anyway,
that's sort of the story that's going
on and it's like very well refracted
reflected.
Um, so, so when you played this
year, do you think it per tape,
because we do have the text or do you
think of particular moments in the poem?
Oh, really? Most of them. You
want to put a play one in Georgia?
Yeah. Well the water is, is
happens throughout the whole piece.
There's constant running
notes and the whole thing.
Okay.
Interestingly enough,
would that cord is an augmented
triad? I had, I cheated. Okay.
Are you supposed to know a
recognize an augmented triad? No,
I did go get the score
in this cause I don't,
I didn't know this piece
particularly well. Um, uh, so no,
you're not supposed to recognize a whole
tone scale from a pentatonic scale.
Maybe recognize it's something different,
but it is interesting to note,
it starts right off the bat with
an augmented triad. So that's the,
that's the water that
um,
and then you're the end.
Well and then it sort of gets really
tumultuous when she's getting really
passionate.
Okay. You want me to play? I'll play
a little of that. That'd be great.
That's sort of what she's getting really
passionate and really pleading with him
to come.
Hello.
Um,
does that sound easy or hard to play?
There's a reason she's playing
this and I am not. Um, yeah,
cause that's how I took the easy stuff.
Big Chords, you know, not that. No.
You should look at the score.
Uh,
and the other interesting thing is that
the hamp is the core positionings change
each time they go up an octave.
And that's really hard. Uh,
rather than repetition of
an arpeggio up an octave,
repeated same hand position up an octave.
The particular hand positions are
changing as you go up. Octave, octave,
two octave. Um, anything else?
I at the very beginning of this,
I did notice if you could
play the left hand part,
just so we can hear this
melody at the beginning.
Okay. So that we have the outlines of,
of a pentatonic scale at work here.
And you're going to hear that at the
beginning and then you'll hear at,
at the end.
So the general form here as is often
true with these impressionist composers,
is just turn reform a, be a
with the, the second and final,
a slightly modified. So we're going to
hear this now from beginning to end.
They owe me woo playing own dean by Ravel.
Okay.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
Hello?
No.
Okay.
[inaudible]
hmm.
Oh,
okay.
[inaudible]
has
on Dean flies off. Oh, you will
fly off now to your next class.
Thanks very much.